how's it goin breath - and welcome back
to Walking Dead DLC 400 days we have one
guy left
and his name is wet and wet has a white
hand what is wack what wants to why a
man woman named an hour that way
Jesus I should like some minute Cisco
unspoken
well the most intense one from what I
heard from you Burris for only 41 days
in god this is so fun that guy man what
the hell was that mean to do it it just
happened okay where the [ __ ] were you
putting that Amina I didn't see the guy
either I was too worried those dudes
were gonna pull guns on a [ __ ] it's like
young early or something sighs [ __ ] just
oh my foot
okay thanks
all right el Diablo
and the habla I'm not moving my arm but
I'm moving me in somehow
and the oblong vodka el Diablo laughing
Siana
why do are they there or not come on
Wyatt talk words at me man I think that
guy's crashed in your crash
did you hear a crash kinda No
I saw something I don't know if that's a
good idea breasts I think we just should
have stayed on the road
feel that look on me man I'm not being
an [ __ ] I'm being smart
no lights no you know they can't see us
okay you're a genius my mouth I don't
think it's mine I can't see a damn thing
out here crashing into a cow ain't gonna
help it cows then again shout for cows
cows
why didn't I think of that the last time
you saw a cow dude okay that example but
you could still hit something man [ __ ]
don't barf just yet okay
please this road is really straight
we'll be fine just drive slow okay at
least slow down what [ __ ] no did you see
that one guy's eyes man he's [ __ ]
gorked I don't want that guy in my life
Wyatt you are covered in that guy's
blood you are covered in that guy's
blood
I know Wyatt my shirt is soaked it's
like I just why didn't they say anything
guys taking his [ __ ] over there that's
all they had to say I told you not to
keep that gun on you [ __ ] right off
Wyatt those guys were going to kill us
and take all our [ __ ] you don't know
that yes I do young Lea's better save
your chubby ass hey I'm not wise
I'm not tubby all I know is those guys
had me all jacked up like I was on speed
or something I was just on edge you know
no I [ __ ] don't it was like watching
that guy's brains
sico warning sorry man
well thanks for getting us out of there
thanks for getting us out anyway
well I'm glad Eddie if it wears the cows
who'd be fun if they hit a cow it's
about time I will punch your eyes don't
that why my eyes not punch my eyes see
it's fine
roads straight is my dick okay now you
just [ __ ] make me uncomfortable think
we're in the clear don't talk about
you're not what
all right let's Tom Cruise out of here
really see if there's still any sticky
in the glove box
but they gonna run Top Gun see dude in
there look harder I don't see it what I
do see is that ammo that you lost last
week oh my god
really but is there any weed you know
one time I was going out with the girl
right have a gill thanking the gun is
probably more important right this
second Thanks okay weird but okay
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's the cow faster cow it was a
walker just keep walking I mean driving
holy [ __ ] did you get a look I think
that was a guy Wyatt a guy Sam come on
man say something was that a dude or not
I think that was a cow [ __ ] fog this
night is so [ __ ] man I think it I think
he was alive well he ain't anymore
let's see if there's anything around the
car you know anything that'll like tell
us one way or the other that way we can
just book but I'm not leaving if we hit
a human being man I'm just not what the
[ __ ] he's morals are so [ __ ] up I
don't understand if he's good or bad man
don't roll it down broken I can't see
through the cracks look it's fine see uh
no dude what's that on the broken side
mirror it's part of a shirt I think yeah
but plenty of dead guys have shirts on
keep looking you think that blood on the
windshield is fresh or rotten does that
blood look fresh to you yeah but it's
kind of dark yeah
damn dad way out in the road is that the
mirror from the car can't tell from here
I don't like where this is going really
not seeing anything it's gonna he's
gonna jump scare us man don't look at
yourself this is serious I wasn't
whatever man keep looking
look Wyatt
it was a guy are you sure yes how sure
pretty [ __ ] sure
don't [ __ ] with tiny Carlos sure Jesus
so what do we do I don't know we do we
go out there we got that what go out
there and what find the guy and help him
who the hell are you tonight if it's a
guy it's a guy I saw him come on man
this is stupid we go out there we check
it out we get moving I'll go give me the
gun
fine I'll go give me the gun dude I'm
the one who got us into this I'm the one
who hit him should be me going so why
did you ask yeah sorry
next time I get into this exact crazy
[ __ ] situation I'll figure out how I
feel before I talk [ __ ] idiot he
looks like an idiot and the other one is
an idiot this is not a good combination
if you ask me [ __ ] okay here we'll
rock-paper-scissors for it
okay fine let's [ __ ] do it fine okay
cool good this is good
we need to hurry up well no [ __ ] you're
ready Rock I'm doing this [ __ ] dude two
seconds it's over all right two out of
three right sure
one two three go yeah all right okay all
right one two
hey go [ __ ] ah paper never wins dude
well it just [ __ ] did your [ __ ]
are you gonna play this game or not no
I've met two not three okay well damn it
Wyatt
if you didn't want to do this you should
have just said Christ looks like to me
too bad
all right come on - it can't be that bad
- just go out alone
okay Eddie
hey man don't leave me the [ __ ] alone
alright this is my speed daddy you
should get back in the car no [ __ ]
way man what it was you here in case we
need to get out of here quick oh that
means we are gonna get out of here quick
what way to go idiot what happened did
it hey why you
I ate tape when I was a kid door what L
do they go is the smallest hope dealer
world hey maybe you can see better with
that guy on
why don't what what was that
but Eddie's upset about that he loves
this car I don't notice then I'm staying
right here
are you are you piece of [ __ ]
why didn't you just oh oh I'm so
confused I'm such an idiot
I need to make you [ __ ] oh oh oh
whoa hi I'm cha may be gentle oh that's
the guy that's the [ __ ] guy okay
the gear be gentle
I'm chopping I'm chopping to chop no way
okay start the engine
I left Eddie behind No
no no no no no no every [ __ ] time I
made it exactly I made the wrong after
wrong after wrong after wrong decision
okay here we go that's what I
anticipated though the 400 days in thing
we were right there are survivors out
here and I'm five I think around five I
think they left a note so at least we
know they won't want to be found and I
can see smoke in the distance probably a
can I'm gonna try to make contact
tonight
what is she cared about exam ease I love
the music Sound Check is awesome
I'm really curious how this all that's
gonna wrap up together you know so far
so good
sittin shouldn't they ever heard her hey
don't do it oh don't joking move who the
[ __ ] are you my name is Tavia how did
you find us you look like Oprah I found
your note I found your note whose idea
was that a scout for a growing
settlement up north we go out and look
for survivors to rescue them
we have food clean water and shelter for
everyone we're offering you a chance to
help us out and start over
god this sounds too good to be true but
I think it is funny get real just
because she says it's true doesn't mean
it is now that's [ __ ] you should know
about that Hey what I told Leila I heard
rumors about these places this guy I was
traveling with ditch me trying to find
one in his own he thought you know what
let's do this
she looks well-fed right and clean we
could all use a meal and a hot shower
yeah yeah you can do that wait you find
survivors do you find a lot not as many
anymore what well we gotta go Eddie
might be there why uh we need people
plain and simple
you folks can decide if you want to come
as a group or split up or whatever but I
don't want to be out here in the open
after dark so in a few minutes I'm gonna
be getting back in my car and on my way
hopefully at least some of you will
follow me why wouldn't they all follow
you well I'm going maybe we should go to
sis
if Roman is still looking for us he
wouldn't be able to do anything to us
there there's no way that guy is still
looking for you we've been to that truck
stop there's no one left Romans not a
problem it's following her that'll get
you killed well I know it's a risk but
what else is there if you guys are going
then so are we
I don't like this guys we should just
walk away I don't trust it
of course you don't wrestle you don't
trust anyone why would he what will it
take to convince you I don't know
Russell come on I don't understand what
the problem is are you really
considering staying out here foraging
for food like [ __ ] raccoons I mean
then why did we even leave the photos
there well it could be a trap what if
they want to kill us thank you
everyone out there is batshit crazy
we've all seen it well we turned out all
right didn't we relatively speaking
you clearly outnumber me so difficult
our me you could hell I'll even go along
as your hostage until you feel safe no
one is gonna hurt you that's not a bad
idea actually ha ha ha because I know
when you guys see this place you'll
change your mind I don't know about this
brother look I know you guys are weary
and you have every right to be you don't
know me from a hole in the ground and
yeah there are some crazy [ __ ] out
there all I'm here to do is make an
offer you can come with me or you could
stay here the choice is yours I don't
know I don't know I don't know so who
wants to come with me I want to come
without bruh
we didn't go without breath honestly did
we get to choose
No okay they choose by themself
yeah I'm going
yeah I have to
I don't know
flapper yeah that's right um I'm not
sure we've been out here for so long and
seen so much [ __ ] but is it really
worth getting out hopes up of course it
is Russell hope is all we've got left
but being smart that's what's keeping us
alive we have people of all ages in our
College how is that a commoners whole
families it's a chance to reconnect with
people the way you used to
we understand I think we've all made up
our minds good well hell good I guess we
have our group she was as a me all alone
what do you want to do with these eat
them
this is a good thing and now it is
we've been we're not even gonna see the
colonies but they told me that was gonna
be cameos of people from season as how
do we know one or whatever
I give you my word
who can not trust that you gotta have
some serious trust issues if you don't
trust Oprah saying that really really
really really really Danny or Justin
who's I okay I agree I kind of [ __ ] up
on that one I really thought that Danny
I was gonna say the other guy by
shooting his chain off so I was gonna go
with him and instead I [ __ ] kill him
so I'm sorry about that one so did you
stay in the car or get out fifty percent
stayed in the car fifty percent did not
did you leave Nate or stay with him
seven times a year yeah why that why
wouldn't you and that was just [ __ ] up
why would you kill an old couple and he
clearly met before
so did you lie to Leland did I lie to
Leland did a lot of Leland delight well
it seems the only thing I [ __ ] up over
I was the the Danny's foot thing so I
left with Tavia okay though the only one
to stay with the Campbells that guy
which is understandable because he
probably had some serious [ __ ] trust
issues by now
and that was the walking name 408 yeehuh
beautiful soundtrack they all have a
beautiful song here in the end
beautiful beautiful men
I don't know I don't know what to say to
that it was really nice and fun to
revisit the world of The Walking Dead
for another moment but I don't know it
just it didn't work for me as I hope
today if the wrap-up in the end I mean
well a sign was that it they have a
shelter ooh that's pretty lame let's be
honest that's pretty lame they could
have had something more I thought they
would do something more smart with it
that they all come together in some I
don't [ __ ] know I don't know I guess
the only things that wrap up and that
each segment was so short cuz it was
like oh it's over
well oh I thought it was just getting
interesting and then you go to the next
one that's the only bad things with her
as it was really good it was fun and
like I said fun to revisit the world up
then with the awakened 8 super pumped
for as season 2 finally we can have some
more climbing crew you know I think
that's that's something to really look
forward to and all that jazz hopefully
by now I will have my new computer I'm
recording on my laptop and I can barely
I can barely record this game it side of
the call it isn't perfect and stuff like
that guy in the car is like what the
hell you taking pictures what the [ __ ]
man I'm at the back feet alright let's
see if there's anything else nope that
was [ __ ] it
alright so people enjoyed watching leave
a like if you did hit subscribe to come
abroad today and say awesome
you